it's great to be joined today by dr.
mona hanna-attisha who is a pediatrician
in Flint Michigan associate professor of
pediatrics at Michigan State University
she was key in exposing the dangerous
levels of lead in Flint Michigan's
drinking water which is a story that
we've been covering for a long time
sadly it the story is not over and we're
going to talk about that in part her new
book is titled what the eyes don't see a
story of crisis resistance and hope in
an American city so let's let's go to
the very beginning if we can how did
this issue of Flint's water problem get
on your radar so it happened very much
by serendipity as a pediatrician I take
care of the children in Flint and moms
were coming in and asking about the
water it was the water safe to use to
bathe my baby was the water safe to use
to mix my baby's formula with us water
and I was very much reassuring my
patients yeah the water's fine
who wouldn't expect in America in the
21st century in the middle of the Great
Lakes for the water that comes out of
your tap not to be okay so I was very
much drinking the kool-aid from the
state reassuring the people that I was
taking care of that the water was okay
so that all changed actually at my home
with a high school girlfriend who
happened to be over for a last minute
barbecue and my girlfriend as a water
expert and she informed me that the
water was not fine it was not safe to
drink and that it wasn't being treated
properly and without the important
ingredient called corrosion control
there was going to be lead in the water
and that was the very first time that I
heard about the possibility of lead a
potent irreversible neurotoxin into our
water supply now when the parents were
coming in and asking you about the
safety of the water was this just
generally something that concerned
parents asked about or was there a
particular reason that the parents were
asking you about this in Flint Michigan
yeah absolutely so the the water switch
happened in April of 2014 and I didn't
get involved until about 17 months late
and throughout this period the people of
Flint were brave and heroic and loud and
organized and they knew something was
wrong with the water so right away the
water looked brown it tasted weird
we had bacteria in the water but then it
was treated with a lot of disinfectant
so they all clear was made and then we
had so much disinfectant which was
chlorine and irritated people's skin and
eyes and then they fixed that so there
were multiple problems with this water
source but with each problem the state
was reassuring the citizens that
everything was okay but really they were
all missed opportunities I think the the
biggest miss opportunity was just a
several several months into the water
switch General Motors which was born in
Flint stopped using this water cuz it
was corroding engine parts imagine that
our water was corroding engine parts but
the people of Flint were being told to
relax that it was okay so I had blinders
on just like many folks in Flint had
blinders on and that's why the title of
this book is what the eyes don't see
because you can't see lead in water and
it's if you can't see the problems with
lead but fundamentally it's about people
and places and problems all over in
Flint and beyond that we choose not to
see and it is our duty to open our eyes
and to be aware of these problems once
you finally realize what was going on
and started making noise about it can
you talk a little bit about what
strategies were used to either try to
discredit the meat of what you were
saying or merely to stop the word from
getting out yeah so you know like I
mentioned the people of Flint were
raising concerns and they were dismissed
so the Flint water crisis is a story of
a denial of democracy denial of the
voice of citizens and very much the
denial of science so I talked about that
basic science of how the engine parts
work voting that was denied everybody
who tried to raise a concern was
discredited and dismissed from the moms
and the activists and the pastors and
the journalists and then the water
scientists came in and said hey look we
have lead in the water this water is 19
times more corrosive than the Great
Lakes water that we had been getting and
though
water scientists were being dismissed so
when I brought forth the data the
research the science that I was
impacting our children and it was
getting in their blood I was also
discredited so Flint is another example
of where science was denied and we see
this nationally happening right now
where clear-cut science on things like
climate change and vaccines are also
being denied so the strategies that we
invoked is is fighting back with more
science you know we every number every
every evidence every fact in my research
was not a number it was a child it was a
childhood I'd probably cared for so we
really fought back with with more
science and and ultimately at that point
the media started to become an important
player in the uncovering of the story
and helped really finally turn the tide
and the state conceded why is lead bad
for the body I mean now we know this for
a long time we didn't and in fact lead
was used in the production of all sorts
of different goods that humans came in
contact with all the time but what are
the health risks that's a great question
David so we've been using lead for
centuries and actually we've known about
its badness for for centuries the Romans
first put lead in there aqueducts the
word lead actually comes from the Latin
plumbum the elemental symbol for lettuce
TB it was so malleable so even back then
many people hypothesize the demise of
Romans was because they used so much
lead not only in plumbing but they also
added it to their food which was
terrible but we put LED in gasoline
because there was a profit to be made
we put lead and paint we have greedily
corporations have put lead in a lot of
industrial goods that have continued to
poison people for generations now and to
come when pediatricians tear the word
lead we really freak out because we know
what it does to children it is potent it
is irreversible
it is a neurotoxin it fundamentally
attacks the everything of what a child
is and does it impacts cognition how
children think dropping IQ levels it
impacts behavior causes the Bell
mental developmental delays and it's
even been linked to criminalities so
levels that we thought were okay decades
ago incredible science has now taught us
that there is no safe level of lead in a
child so yes it's been great that
people's lead levels have been dropping
over the last few decades as we got let
out of paint and gasoline but we should
be paying more attention because we now
know there is no safe level and we also
know that the lowest levels can actually
cause considerable decline in children's
cognition and behavior and what's most
striking is that lead as a form of
environmental injustice a form of
environmental racism our kids in Flint
already had higher blood levels just
like kids in Detroit and Chicago in
Baltimore and some of these cities with
our most vulnerable children are already
disproportionately exposed to lead we
sometimes in corporate media we see that
stories go away after they've sort of
run their course but that doesn't
necessarily mean the problem has been
solved we saw this for example in the
aftermath of the hurricanes in Puerto
Rico which is a really notable example
just because we're not hearing as much
about what's going on in Flint at this
point in corporate media is everything
fine now with the water there
no and that's absolutely why I wrote
this book when I started this two and a
half years ago I knew that we would need
a way to shine a spotlight back on Flint
because our story is nowhere near over
our we had 18 months of corrosive water
that ran through our system that ate off
our pipes those are being replaced so
that's that's great news but until those
are replaced people still are on
filtered water and bottled water but
where I spend most of my time is in
terms of the recovery of the children we
can't take away this crisis but we are
very much and very much what this book
hopes to share is a story of resistance
of activism and of hope so science was
denied in Flint science ultimately spoke
truth to power and we are using the
incredible science of child development
and resilience to buffer the impact of
this crisis and that is that is hope and
that is what we're hoping to share so we
have things in place in Flint that
aren't being done anywhere else in this
country for example child care services
and home visiting programs and universal
preschool and early literacy support a
Medicaid expansion so but these are
things that all children need everywhere
so we are leveraging this crisis to make
sure that our children who did nothing
wrong besides live in a city that was
almost bankrupt lost democracy and
didn't treat its water properly do not
see the consequences of this crisis so
so that is what is happening Flint so
Flint is really a model of of a crisis
but really a model of how we can turn
this crisis around and really serve as
an example to other communities where
children are suffering from very similar
toxicities via the toxicity of poverty
or violence or lost democracy the book
is great but it is about a very very
dark chapter in American history I mean
I don't think that that that's going too
far to say that the book is called what
the eyes don't see a story of crisis
resistance and hope in an American city
we've been speaking with the book's
author dr. mona hanna-attisha thank you
so much and and thank you so much for
exposing this because it is it could
have easily been covered up for much
longer and we're all it's horrible but
we're all better off that it was exposed
when it did and not a year or two later
it's true
thank you